Jenelle Evans hospitalized after an
alleged assault incident I have no idea
of no idea about anything
authorities allegedly responded to a 911
call over the weekend and dispatched
police officers to investigate a
reported assault at the Teen Mom 2 star
and her husband David Easton's North
Carolina home what are we gonna do we
need to contact someone I'll freak out
you know that if I have to stay in this
house another day et has learned the
initial ambulance requested was
cancelled and Evans was brought to the
hospital by private car no arrests were
made and a police report was not filed
this isn't the first time the 26 year
old star has been faced with controversy
- no please please don't do anything
please do anything after frequent
arguments with her ex Nathan Griffith
who she shares son Kaiser with Evans was
arrested for domestic violence charges
following an altercation he later
dropped all charges
the most recent alleged assault comes
just months after Evans road rage
incident where she pulled out a gun in
the car while her 9 year old son Jace
was with her she later accused her son
of life the reality star opened up about
her initial denial to dr. drew on the
Teen Mom 2 reunion episode I was really
desperate at the time that and when he
said oh yeah mommy pulled out her gun I
was like no I didn't why should you say
that because I don't want to get
arrested for something stupid have you
circled back around to help him
understand why you did that yes I
definitely told him I said listen I was
like I don't want the police thinking
the wrong thing if they hear you say
that I don't care if you tell meh me I
told my mom after we were done filming I
told her I'm not afraid it says she
knows
[Music]